[Musique]
Idrissam. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit pour vos secteurs d'activité, vos
conférences, votre domaine de
compétences. Est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on commence par le dur ou le soft ?
Toujours le plus dur. entré de jeu.
Tu entré de jeu ?
Tu es un myth ou tu es pas un mytho ?
J'ai trois doctorats. Il y en a qui
pleurent du sang là-dessus mais j'ai
trois doctorats. Et je sais que ça fait
mal parce que j'ai été prédoctorant de
l'École normale supérieure à 19 ans. À
21 ans, j'ai été chercheur invité à
Stanford. 20 ans précisément. Je me
rappelle, je m'étais fait jeter de boîte
à l'époque. Je pouvais pas rentrer en
club. C'est un de mes plus un de mes
pires souvenirs. Je vais à New York avec
la fille avec qui j'étais et je savais
pas tu sais que aux États-Unis tu
pouvais pas rentrer en boîte comme ça
avant 21 ans. Je me suis dit [__] je
suis visiting scolaire de l'université
de Stanford, ils vont me laisser
rentrer. Je me suis fait lourder d'une
boîte à New York. Mais tout ça c'est
vrai et je sais que pour certains c'est
très très dur à digérer.
Comment tuexpliques ça ?
J'adore ce que je fais. Et ça c'est un
sujet si tu veux qui crée une dissonance
cognitive essentielle parce qu'il y a
plein de gens dans ce monde et ça c'est
le sujet de mon travail et de mes
conférences qui pensent que si tu ne
prends si tu ne souffres pas si tu es
pas en train de te faire des mil check
au prosac tous les matins, tu ne peux
pas être productif. Tu as des gens qui
ont un logiciel qui tourne au fond de
leur tête qui est que la méritocratie en
fait c'est la souffrancratie et que si
tu es vraiment pas en train d'être
dépressif de souffrir, tu ne peux pas
travailler. Je te rappelle et tu le sais
mieux que moi que l'étymologie du mot
travail c'est tripalium, l'instrument de
torture.
Il y a quelques papiers qui ont été
écrits là-dessus qui ont été sourcés.
Est-ce que tu penses que c'est une
mauvaise interprétation de ta
présentation par les journalistes ou
est-ce que tu as gonflé ton CV ? tu l'as
un peu amélioré ou
dis-moi ce qui est vrai. Dis-moi
simplement ce qui est vrai. On va faire
du vrai journaliste. Je suis
journaliste. Je suis éditorialiste. Oui,
mais moi je suis journaliste.
Une carte de presse.
Alors, mais avoir une carte de presse
signifie absolument pas qu'on est
journaliste. Ça veut simplement dire
qu'on tire l'essentiel de ces revenus du
journalisme. Mais dis-moi ce qui est
vrai. Dis-moi simplement ce qui est vrai
dans ce qu'ils ont écrit.
On a on a une phrase qui dit "Je viens à
vous sans mes médailles, mais uniquement
avec mes succès." Sans mes titres, mais
uniquement avec mes succes. Je suis
d'accord avec ça et je serais le premier
à brûler tous mes titres s'il le
fallait. Si tu veux, mon père m'avait
dit et beaucoup de gens, tu sais, j'ai
grandi en banlieu
en France. Moi, j'ai grandi à Cheville
la rue aussi du côté d'Atismont, tu
sais, la Belle épine et cetera. C'était
plutôt une banlieue chaude quand même.
J'ai pas j'ai pas grandi dans des dans
un environnement. Moi, je suis né en 86,
donc l'époque de Ternobyl et j'ai vu des
bagnoles qui cramaient. J'ai vu mon
franchin courser des mecs qui avaient
cramé des bagnoles et si tu veux, je
venais d'un milieu où tu t'en sortais
que en étant rappeur, footballeur ou
dealer. La voix des trois doctorats
Normal Sup dont un doctorat de l'École
polytechnique, Visiting Scolar à
Stanford, affiliate scolar 8 ans à
Stanford, professeur à central, chargé
de cours
polytechnique, c'est Polytechnique. Ils
ont dit que c'était pas Polytechnique.
Ils ont rien dit du tout. J'ai un
doctorat, je suis docteur de l'école
polytechnique. Tu as un canard qui a dit
que j'étais enseignant chercheur là-bas.
Moi, je n'ai jamais signé ça et je ne
suis jamais revendiqué d'être enseignant
chercheur.
Question question d'internet, comment
a-t-il fait pour faire trois tests de
2013 à 2016 ?
J'ai beaucoup travaillé. Il y a des gens
qui ont du mal à voir ça, qui ont du mal
à se rendre compte de ça. Je travaille
comme un tinré. Je fais à peu près des
journées de 15h depuis 2006.
On a vu récemment à R sur Image
faire une émission concernant le fait
que ton éditeur poursuivait certains
sites internet. Je sais pas s'il les
poursuivent, j'ai pas tellement suivi
ça. Mais ce que je sais c'est qu'ils
veulent rétablir la vérité. Tu vois,
eux, ils mettent, ils ont bien mis mon
CV à la fin du livre, trois doctorat,
prédoctorants de l'École normale
supérieure à 19 ans, visiting scolar de
l'université Stanford à 20 ans. Tu as
des gens qui ne l'acceptent toujours
pas. Bon eux, si tu veux, mon éditeur,
je pense que son vrai intérêt ça aurait
été de laisser faire puisqu'en fait
cette polémique, elle m'a rapporté il
faut être prosaï avec beaucoup d'argent.
Je veux dire, mon livre était parti pour
se vendre à 30000 exemplaires.
Tu payes tes impôts
? 40000 en France pour l'instant. Il est
pas exclu que je l'ai paye plus tard
parce que ailleurs puisque je suis expat
maintenant. Mais en France, tu sais,
j'ai été officier de marine en France he
donc j'ai une certaine FIP patriote.
J'ai été officier de Marine Marine quel
grade ?
Euh
sur quel bâtiment ?
Donc c'était enseigne de vaisseau de 2è
classe et j'ai été notamment sur le
Mistral. Ouais,
sur le Mistrral
fameux et aussi sur le transport de
chalant de débarquement euh Siroco mais
réserviste.
Bon, maintenant qu'on a éclusé le
problème euh je
on peut continuer toute la soirée. Tu
sais moi j'adore ce genre de ce genre de
polémique parce que pour moi c'est un
diagnostic. Moi je suis là pour faire
des diagnostics sur la société et
notamment sur cette maladie française du
reste à ta place. Cette maladie
française tu sais du liberté, égalité
fraternité. Non, reste à ta place.
C'est-à-dire quand quelqu'un émerge en
France, on va déjà sentir on t'a déjà
fait sentir tes origines
toute ma vie. Et tu sais que cette
polémique
mais de de d'abord frontalement
salarabe, ça m'est arrivé plein de fois.
Je te rappelle que cette polémique a
alimenté un un site d'extrême droite
bien connu qui s'en est régalé et qui
s'appelle f de souche pour ne pas le
citer. Donc le racisme, j'ai connu ça
toute ma vie et je me suis battu contre
lui toute ma vie. J'ai été au scoutot
musulman de France. On se battait
notamment contre la radicalisation en
banlieu mais aussi contre le racisme.
J'ai toujours été aux avant-postes du
combat de la fraternité en France mais
le problème de la fraternité c'est que
ça se décrète pas. Ça ét au scout ça a
été été au scout par ton père.
Oui, c'est ça. Bon, on a éclusé le
bordel. Si vous avez encore des
questions, essayez faites faites-les
nous remonter par Discord. J'aimerais
qu'on parle de la guerre. H parlons-en.
Euh
ton avis sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment avec la Russie, avec les
États-Unis, avec Trump, avec Kim Jung,
avec ce qui se passe en Afrique, les
flux migratoire, je te laisse commencer
en fait. Alors là, ça fait beaucoup de
choses en même temps, mais
on a le temps.
On est en gar froide 2.0. C'est pas un
terme que j'ai inventé. C'est un terme
qui existe, je crois, depuis quasiment
la Yugoslavie, la guerre froide 2.0.
C'est-à-dire que tous les enjeux
géopolitiques de la guerre froide sont
là avec deux blocs qui s'opposent mais
c'est plus idéologique. Avant avant
c'était pas idéologique non plus pour
être tout à fait honnête, c'était
géopolitique. Il suffit de regarder une
carte du monde centrée sur le pôle nord
pour voir qu'on a le même problème entre
la Russie et l'OTAN, les États-Unis
qu'il y avait entre Rome et Carthage.
Rome et Cartage se battaient pour
l'hégémonie en mer méditerranée. La
Russie et l'Alliance Atlantique Nord se
battent pour l'hégémonie pour l'instant
autour du pôle Nord. Tu as la Chine
notamment qui a lancé cette fameuse
initiative des routes de la soie
arctique. La Chine s'est faite
reconnaître comme une puissance arctique
ce qu'elle n'est pas mais ce qu'elle est
du point de vue commercial. C'est du
point de vue géographique, elle n'a pas
d'accès à l'Arctique. Mais du point de
vue commercial pour elle ces routes-là
représenteraient euh les nouvelles
routes de la soie. Et ça évidemment
comme tu le sais sans doute aussi mieux
que moi, quasiment toutes les guerres
ont été décidées pour des problèmes de
route commerciale, de flux commerciaux.
Les croisades, c'était pas du tout pour
aller récupérer Jérusalem au départ,
c'était la route de la soie et la route
des épices. La route des épices, il faut
pas oublier qu'à l'époque les épices te
rapporter un ratio supérieur à la
cocaïne. Aujourd'hui, quand tu prenais
du poivre assez lent et que tu le
ramenais en Europe, tu faisais un ratio
supérieur à quelqu'un qui vend de la
coke en l'achetant en Bolivie et
l'amenant. France, chiffres, tu les
tiens d'où ? des historiens ont sorti
ça. Je vais essayer de te retrouver les
références si tu veux mais bon là on est
on est spontané évidemment donc tu as
bien compris que je vais pas te citer
Chapiro 2007 et Johnson 92 mais tu peux
retrouver les chiffres sur Google Books
si tu regardes. Et le sujet donc de ces
routes commerciales et bien c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a le même. Les
États-Unis contrôlent tous les D3 et
tous les choke points dans le monde
aujourd'hui avec la plus grande flotte
sur terre et ça envisage évidemment une
confrontation avec la Chine et la
Russie. Et cette confrontation, elle
sera pas de haute intensité comme on dit
ou chaude parce qu'il y a l'arme
nucléaire, mais elle en demeure pas
moins violente. Violente dans le sens
qu'il y a toujours des conflits
périphériques, ce qu'on appelle des
guerres par proxy. Il y en a eu au
Soudan, il y en a aujourd'hui en Syrie
qui est un verrouier bien connu dans
laquelle la Russie a pris part.
On pourrait envisager des solutions plus
pacifiques si on avait une diplomatie
plus J'ai pas peur d'utiliser le mot
technologique. Euh j'ai fait mon mon
premier doctorat sur la géopolitique de
la connaissance et l'idée que la
connaissance permettait de transcender
des conflits. C'est-à-dire que une
opposition frontale en particulier sur
des ressources et bien pouvait être
transcendé par un ajout de connaissance
au conflit. Et il y a eu assez de
d'exemples dans l'histoire de ce de ce
phénomène là. Je pense qu'il est urgent
de le faire parce qu'au 21e siècle, on
pourrait pas se permettre un conflit de
haute intensité.
La Suède, tu suis un peu en ce moment ?
Alors, un petit peu de loin, si j'ai
bien compris, ils sont plus tellement
neutres. Bon, c'est ils l'ont jamais
vraiment été. Mais tu faisais référence
à quelle à quelle nouvelle en
particulier ?
Le fait qu' réimprime un petit bouquin
pour leur population concernant la
guerre avec la Russie.
Ah oui, voilà. Ouai, c'est ça. Alors,
moi, je vis et je travaille en Suisse.
Mes investisseurs sont en Suisse, ma
fondation est en Suisse. J'ai étudié
pour ma première thèse le manuel de Hans
VAR
qui s'appelle Résistance totale et qui
est connu. J'aime beaucoup ce manuel
parce que en fait c'est l'opposé de la
pensée française en 40 pour être
honnête. C'est le meilleur manuel de
Guerria au monde réputé à l'époque comme
un des meilleurs manuels encore
aujourd'hui. Tu as bien sûr les manuels
de Mao et les manuels de du Cheegevara.
Mais Hans VAR, il a écrit un manuel sur
comment résister à un occupant
et comment résister de façon totale.
C'est-à-dire qu'il écrit par exemple
dans son manuel un détail qui m'a
toujours bouleversé. Il dit la
résistance totale, c'est par exemple si
vous êtes vous travaillez pour l'ennemi,
il vous a réquisitionné comme femme de
ménage et vous repasser ses pantalons et
bien euh repasser ces pantalons un peu
plus longtemps chaque jour parce que ça
va les user davantage et du coup vous
aurez fait votre contribution à l'effort
de guerre. Cette mentalité là si tu veux
crée ce que Jomini avait appelé un pays
qui ne peut pas être enveille. Pour la
Suède, tu fais bien de le souligner
parce que tu sais que les Suédois ont
inventé un char. Un char pour leur
terrain, un char pour défendre leur
territoire. J'ai oublié le nom de ce
char mais c'est un char sans tourelle
avec un un camouflage en rateau à
l'avant qui est fait pour tirer en
anticlean. Tu sais, c'est une technique,
tu places ton char de l'autre côté d'une
pente, il y a que le canon qui dépasse
et comme le terrain suédois est
parfaitement adapté à ce genre de
position défensive, ils avaient mis au
point un char comme ça. La Suède est un
pays qui a une mentalité de la
résistance totale assez forte, mais le
fait qu'il ressorte ses manuels et ses
ces état d'urgence, on pourrait dire ça
comme ça, géopolitiquement, ça peut pas
être interprété comme quelque chose de
positif. Je vois pas de quelle manière
ça peut être interprété comme quelque
chose de positif.
Tu tu suis d'autres conflits. L'Ukraine,
ça te parle un peu ?
J'ai vécu en Ukraine. J'ai vécu 9 mois
en Ukraine. C'est un pays que j'ai
vraiment beaucoup aimé.
Pour moi, vraiment,
on aurait pu éviter ce conflit. Je j'en
suis convaincu. Il fait pas partie des
conflits inévitables. Aujourd'hui, il a
un tel niveau de polarisation
que je vois très mal, comment il
pourrait être résolu pacifiquement. Bon,
bien entendu, euh l'Ukraine seule
pourrait pas résister à la Russie très
longtemps. Donc l'Union européenne a
pris un parti qu'elle qu'on assume, les
États-Unis aussi. référendum quand même.
Ah sur l'Ukraine oui. Non mais là je te
parle de résistance militaire quoi. Le
référendum, ça c'est effectivement un
sujet, il est évident que les Ukrainiens
veulent pouvoir faire des Erasmus,
échanger avec l'Europe. Mais au-delà de
ça, pour moi, celui qui a le mieux
compris ce sujet euh c'était feu Sbigiev
Brésski. Bon voilà, Sbigev Brésski, on
va rentrer dans le vif du sujet. Euh
pourvoyeur de mort,
c'est Dark Vador. Mais c'est quelqu'un
de brillant. C'est ça le problème si tu
veux. c'est que c'est Dark Vador mais
c'est quelqu'un de brillant. Et du coup
Dark Vador, il a écrit des livres. Tu
vois, si tu pouvais lire un livre écrit
par Dark Vador, je pense que éch
le grand échiquier c'est le plus cité.
Et effectivement dans le grand
échiquier, pour parler de celui-là, il a
clairement dit et il a raison puisque il
est géopolitologue, donc il sait de quoi
il parle. La Russie sans l'Ukraine cesse
d'être une puissance européenne.
Il ne faut pas oublier que l'OTAN a été
créé nominalement et je ne prends pas
partie hein. Je je pense que cette cet
enjeu de l'OTAN est était comment dire
je vais pas dire légitime parce que ça
serait prendre partie mais se comprenait
des mots du premier général qui a qui
était le premier sa sœur tu sais le
grand grand manitou de l'OTAN en Europe.
L'OTAN a été créé pour si je me souviens
bien dans l'ordre keep the Russians out.
Keep the Germans down and keep America
in. Donc garder les Américains en
Europe, virer les Russes et réduire la
puissance de l'Allemagne surtout après
la réunification. Bon, l'OTAN a été créé
bien avant bien entendu. Mais un de ces
enjeux était celui-là.
Tu as entendu parler de cette fameuse
cette fameuse épisode où Sarkozi avait
rencontré Poutine et où Poutine lui
aurait mis le coup de pression de sa
vie.
Il est ressorti un peu bourré.
Oui. Alors là, en fait, tu sais bien que
Sarco ne boit pas. Donc il était pas
bourré. choqué
mais il était choqué.
Poutine a une une excellente compétence
en guerre psychologique. C'est son
métier. C'està-dire qu'il a été formé à
la guerre psychologique. Et dans la
guerre psychologique, on doit savoir que
l'humain est une mosaïque de besoins et
que si tu réagis à ses besoins et à ses
ficelles, tu peux le manipuler. Par
exemple, quand Poutine a rencontré
George Bouche, il lui a raconté
l'histoire du moment où sa data avait
brûlé et la seule chose qu'il avait
gardé, c'était sa croix. Ça a touché
Bouche mais vénère. ça a touché Bush au
fond de lui-même et tu voyais tout le
staff de Bush dieu !
Alors ça c'est ça va vachement vite là
pour pour moi même moi tu vois euh je
vais finir sur ça et je vais te répondre
après à cette excellente question. Ce
que je veux donc dire c'est que Poutine
en garde psychologique il est
extrêmement bon et que il avait dit donc
à Sarco, il savait où le frapper,
c'est-à-dire sur son complexe
d'infériorité. Sarco a un complexe
d'infériorité majeur qui est connu à
l'honnête.
Euh oui, ça à la limite c'est le
physique mais moi je te parle plutôt de
l'abandon. Tu vois, il a été abandonné
par son père. C'est quelqu'un qui a
systématiquement peur d'être abandonné
par sa figure tutellaire. Et c'est pour
ça qu'il se sent obligé de trahir si tu
veux ce qui s'est passé avec Pascois, ce
qui s'est passé avec Chirak. C'est un
comportement psychologique bien connu.
Poutine le savait ça. Et donc remettre à
sa place quelqu'un qui a un sentiment de
de peur face au rejet, c'est très
efficace et ça déstabilise. Mais
rappelons-nous ce qu'il avait utilisé
comme argument. Il avait dit "Écoute
bonhomme, ton pays il est grand comme
ça. Mon pays il est grand comme ça." Et
c'est vrai que quand tu vois une carte
du pôle nord, c'est ce qui saute aux
yeux. Donc il lui dit "Garçon, je peux
faire de toi le chef de l'Europe si je
veux ou bien je peux t'écrabouiller."
Bon ça ça calme, ça c'est clair. Que tu
sois le président d'une d'une puissance
nucléaire ou pas, ça te calme. Et euh du
coup ça représente bien les rapports de
force en Europe. C'est-à-dire que
rappelle-toi, Napoléon, il a envahi
l'Italie. Pourquoi ? parce que l'Italie
était divisée. Napoléon, c'était un pays
uni qui était la Chine de l'Europe avec
la plus grosse démographie face à une
petite fédération toute foireuse de
Républiques et puis d'États pontificaux
qui pouvaient pas se saquer entre eux.
Tu rentres là-dedans comme dans du
beurre. La terreur des requins
certainement aussi autoréalisatrice
puisque je te dis que je prendrai pas
partie ce soir. La terreur des requins,
j'insiste certainement autoréalisatrice,
c'est que Poutine rentre dans l'Europe
comme dans du beurre s'ils ne sont pas
là.
Et ça c'est quasiment tous les enjeux de
la géopolitique actuelle.
La Libye c'était bien ou c'était pas
bien ? Tu
demandé pour Dieu du coup ?
Ouais. Non mais on va y revenir aussi.
Tu crois en Dieu ?
Alors voilà. Du coup on verra pour Tu la
gardes de côté.
Non t'inquiète pas on on est multitch.
Alors tu sais qu'instein avait répondu à
cette question et je je peux pas faire
de meilleures réponses que lui de tout.
Plus fait de la science plus je crois en
Dieu. C'est ça ?
Non moi je parle plutôt de Dites-moi ce
que vous appelez Dieu. Je vous dirai si
j'y crois.
Est-ce que tu as un ami imaginaire ?
Quand j'étais petit. Ouais. Mais
maintenant, je me parle à moi-même comme
Vincent Gigante qui une de mes idoles.
Tu te situaerais plus athé plus déiste,
non ?
Non non non, moi je suis souffi.
Soufi ?
Je suis soufi et je suis sur une voie.
J'ai pris le temps de faire un petit
silence parce que ça veut dire quelque
chose. Mais je suis sur une voie bien
précise.
Je m'appelle Idriss parce que mon père
était fan d'Idrce Cha.
Anna Absalam.
Merci. Tu tu connais un petit peu
Idriss Chat ? Euh c'était un grand
maître souffi du 20e siècle qui a été
attaqué toute sa vie. Toute sa vie. Le
type a été le mentor de Doris Lessing,
prix Nobel de littérature. Il a été le
mentor de Ahmad Shah Massoud, le
commandant Massou. Le type était un
maître soufi reconnu par tous les
maîtres soufis. Et des universitaires
français ont dit qu'il n'était pas un
maître soufi. Et moi, je suis sur cette
voie là. Ça c'est mon travail et ça
c'est ce que je fais.
Donc je vais certainement pas dire que
je crois pas en Dieu. Par contre,
le soufi comme tout mystique rejette
tout ce qui réduit Dieu, rejette tout ce
qui rabaisse Dieu. Par exemple, croire
que c'est un grand barbu qui lance des
éclairs. Et ça, j'y crois pas. Le mot
dieu vient du grec Zeus. Le mot dieu
vient de Zeus. Et c'est pour ça que
l'Occident continue. Regarde les
guignoles quand ils font une marionnette
de Dieu, c'est un grand barbu qui lance
des éclairs. Regarde la chapelle 16,
c'est un grand barbu qui lance des
éclair. En anglais, c'est God. God, ça
vient de Votan, Odin. Tu sais que le W
devient j'ai donc Votan, Gotan, God,
Votan, Odin, c'est le dieu des éclairs.
Il y avait autre chose. Il y avait déjà,
c'est une étymologie plus intéressante.
Mais tu reconnais le bigot dans toute
religion, tu reconnais le bigot au fait
qu'il part du principe qu'il sait qui
est Dieu et qu'il sait ce qu'il veut. Tu
le reconnaîtras immédiatement à ça.
Pardon, regarde les croisés desvult.
Le type qui arrive en disant "C'est la
volonté de Dieu, je la connais, il m'a
appelé hier, c'est du bigot 100 % pur
sucre et tu le détectera comme ça." Ça,
quand on est sur une voie et tout ce
qu'on appelle une voix, il faut s'en
écarter comme de la peste.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de l'islam
radical ?
Ben justement, pour moi, c'est pas de
l'islam. Très honnête, ce n'est pas de
l'islam. Le mot radical d'ailleurs n'est
pas du tout bienvenu. Radical, ça veut
dire la racine. C'est quoi leur racine ?
Quelle est leur racine ? Connaissent-ils
l'islam du 7e siècle ? Connaissent-ils
un petit peu ce qui se faisait vraiment
à l'époque, pas les fantasmes de
Disneyland, mais ce qui faisait
vraiment.
Est-ce que tu connais la troisème
sourate ?
Je alors je ne suis pas un hafèz, je
connais pas le Coran par cœur, mais pour
moi, il faut avoir une certaine
sourate du trône.
Oui. Qu'est-ce que tu voudrais dire
dessus ?
Non, non, c'est une sourate qu'on m'a
offerte dans le désert blanc égyptien un
jour.
Moi ma préférée, mais attends pour
revenir, moi ma préférée c'est la
sourate alf. Je
le Coran quand je l'étudie, je suis
extrêmement parsimonieux. Je vais tout
doucement, tu sais, tu as sep niveaux de
lecture et je veux surtout me garder de
l'arrogance qu'on peut avoir quand on
quand on maîtrise trop bien par cœur le
la surface, si tu veux, quand on peut
citer des passages sans avoir bien
compris qu'un passage, c'est comme la
surface d'un océan, il y a des fonds. Et
le corant, c'est vraiment ça, c'est la
surface d'un océan. Tu peux parler de la
surface, mais le vrai océanographe, il
te parle de la totalité de la profondeur
océanographique et de toute la courbe
bâtimétrique. Ça, c'est la différence
entre un océanographe et un mec du club
Med. Le Coran, il faut pas le lire en
mec du club MED, il faut le lire en
océanographe en étant extrêmement humble
et en essayant de pénétrer le sens
profond de chaque passage, en
particulier son étymologie, son contexte
et cetera. Et s'il y a eu des siècles
d'école d'interprétation, c'est
précisément parce que il était admis et
convenu non seulement que le Coran a une
profondeur, mais également que personne
n'a le droit de l'interpréter à votre
place. Vous pouvez être conseillé mais
si vous prenez une interprétation c'est
votre responsabilité. Et d'ailleurs,
c'était la fameuse histoire qu'on avait
dite à Abou Bakr. Je vais faire un temps
de silence pour les les religieux qui
nous regardent. Et bien,
tu peux tu peux faire les
Non, j'aime pas j'ai horreur de
l'ostentation sur ce point-là, mais je
respecte cela dit ceux qui voudraient
que je fasse ce temps de silence, donc
je le fais. Mais tu prends cette fameuse
histoire. On avait demandé à Abou Bakr
qu'est-ce qui est prédestiné dans la vie
et qu'est-ce qui est notre libre arbitre
? Et il avait répondu "Bah lève une
jambe." Alors le type lève une jambe bah
ça c'est ton libre arbitre. Tu as
accepté de m'écouter. Tu aurais pu ne
pas le faire mais tu vas accepter de le
faire. C'est ton libre arbitre. Lève
l'autre jambe maintenant. Le type dit
bah je peux pas. Ah ça c'est la
prédestination. C'est pas toi qui a
choisi d'avoir de jambes. J'aime bien
cette interprétation là sur le libre
arbitre et sur comment dire les règles.
Cette vie tu sais Elon Mus dit que cette
vie est un jeu vidéo, une simulation.
C'est pas si faux. Tu sais que dans le
Hagakouré, il y a l'idée que cette vie
est un rêve. Tu le trouves chez Edgarpo
aussi. Et ce jeu vidéo, il a des règles
qu'on a pas choisi. Ça, on peut
l'appeler la prédestination. La façon
dont on compose avec ces règles, je
pense qu'on peut l'appeler libre
arbitre.
Tes préconisations pour les politiques
de contreradicalisation ? L'islam,
c'est comme les euh d'un point de vue
euh géopolitique, c'est un petit peu
comme notre flore, tu sais, notre flore
commençale, notre flore naturelle.
Si tu veux si tu veux chasser la flore
dangereuse, il faut qu'il y ait une
flore saine. Et moi, je l'ai d'autant
plus connu que je suis d'origine
algérienne et que j'ai vu ce qui s'est
passé en Algérie. C'est-à-dire tu prends
l'époque de Bouédienne, tu prends
l'époque où l'Algérie décide de se la
jouer communiste, plus précisément
soviétique, c'est bien précis, et de de
mettre l'Algérie au congélateur, de
fermer les awouas, de persécuter les
maîtres soufis locaux.
Tu fais ça, dès que le congélateur tombe
en panne, bah tu as une guerre civile.
Et c'est ce qui s'est passé. La guerre
civile n'est pas apparue en 91 en
Algérie pour rien. C'était parce que le
grand frère soviétique n'était plus là
pour faire marcher la machine du grand
froid.
Et donc pour moi la déradicalisation
et bien oui contre c'est termes un peu
fashion euh ne marche que si tu as un
islam sain. Je me suis battu pendant 10
ans contre l'idée d'un clash des
civilisations. ma thèse de littérature
comparée à l'université de Strasbourg
qui est librement consultable en ligne
et bien elle travaille sur le fait que
le clash des civilisations n'existe pas,
que c'est un mythe que s'il existait et
bien jamais la France n'aurait eu comme
plus long allié de son histoire l'Empire
ottoman. Le plus long allié de
l'histoire de France c'est l'Empire
ottoman. L'alliance franco-ottomane qui
a duré même plus longtemps que la
vieille alliance, la hall alliance avec
l'Écosse et cetera et cetera. Edgar Po,
il a écrit un poème qui est inspiré de
la 7e sourate Alraf.
Des tonnes et des tonnes d'exemples. Qui
sait aujourd'hui que le minaret est une
structure d'origine chrétienne. Le
minaret, tu sais, je vis en Suisse, j'ai
vu la votation citoyenne, je la
respecte. Je pense qu'ils ont le droit
de faire des votations citoyennes et
qu'ils doivent le faire. Et ça, j'adore
la démocratie directe en Suisse. Jamais
tu me trouveras pour la critiquer. Mais
le minaret, c'était la mosquée des
omeyadas à Damas qui était une église.
Quand les musulmans sont arrivés à
Damas, c'était l'église de
Saint-Jean-Baptiste. Son tombeau est
encore là d'ailleurs. Et ils ont vu que
les chrétiens d'Orient faisaient des
appels à la prière au VPRE par oral
depuis une tour et ils l'ont copié pour
la mosquée stéréotypée par excellence,
celle de Kerroi en Tunisie qui est
devenue donc le stéréotype de toutes les
mosquées moyen-orientales par la suite.
Cette notion d'un choc des
civilisations, elle est aussi contredite
par le fait que l'immense majorité des
victimes du terrorisme dit islamique
sont des musulmans. Et ça ce sont des
chiffres qui ne peuvent pas mentir.
Quand on regarde combien de personnes
sont tuées par an par des musulmans, par
des terrorismes islamiques, ce sont des
musulmans. Si les terroristes islamiques
cherchaient le clash des civilisations,
ils le cherchent très mal. S'ils étaient
en croisade contre l'Occident, pourquoi
ne tueraient-ils pas les occidentaux en
priorité absolue plutôt que de faire 95
% de victimes musulman ? Là, tu vois le
conflit qu'il y a entre la flore
musulmane naturelle et la flore
musulmane, je n'ai pas peur de le dire,
cancéreuse.
Les préconisations,
tu sais comment on appelle les
bandits en au Mexique ?
Les guerriers où les
Non, les bandits, tu sais, dans les
westerns. Comment on appelle les bandits
dans les westernnes au Mexique ? E c'est
le nom d'une bière
et de Dossekis.
Dosquis le salot. Personne connaît la
Dosequis en France en plus.
Los Desperados,
merci d'avoir fait appel au public. Los
Desperados,
les désespérés.
Tu connais la doquis ?
Ouais mais carrément. J'ai même fait un
dans mon dans mon bouquin, tu as un
sujet sur les les leviers
comportementaux de la publicité
d'Osquis. Pourquoi elle est aussi bonne
? Pourquoi elle fonctionne aussi bien
cette pub avec je bois pas toujours de
la bière mais quand j'en bois je bois de
la doquisse. C'était c'est une pub qui
est dans tous les manuels aujourd'hui
hein qui est
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé.
Absolument. Mais donc Los Despelados
on n'est pas obligé de le dire. En plus
on n'est pas sur une chaîne de télé je
crois. Euh l'espados, si tu veux si tu
veux lutter contre le contre la
radicalisation, il faut lutter contre le
désespoir. Et c'est précisément pour ça
que les scoutes musulmans de France ont
été créés, hein. C'était c'était euh
pour euh pour donner de l'espoir dans
les banlieux. Quand tu as 30 % de
chômage entre pour les chez les 25 35
ans, comment tu veux parler d'espoir ?
Comment tu veux parler d'espoir ? Moi,
j'ai travaillé comme un timbré pour m'en
sortir. Tu as vu ce que ça a donné
d'ailleurs ? Parfois, je me dis que
j'aurais fait aussi. Oui, c'est vrai.
Mais alors, c'est loin d'être suffisant.
Crois-moi. C'est c'est très très loin
d'être suffisant. J'ai vu plein de mes
camarades que je connais bien sûr dont
je terra le nom qui avaient des parents
et euh qui n'ont pas suivi le même
chemin. Et puis parfois parmi les
radicalisés, tu es le premier à le
savoir, il y a tout un tas d'érudits euh
de gens qui euh qui ont bac + 5, qui ont
euh un niveau d'étude tout à fait euh
tout à fait conséquent, qui sont pas du
tout dépumés comme on comme on voudrait
le croire, mais qui sont si qui sont
paumés en un sens, mais pas dans le sens
que la République considère être paumé
dans un autre sens, dans un sens
psychologique, dans un sens de repère,
dans le sens de la vie.
Pourquoi tu dis qu'ils sont paumés ?
Attention, c'est pas
J'ai été haatif là-dessus. Bon, pour
moi, quand tu décides de tuer quelqu'un
en te faisant sauter et que c'est pas
pour de l'autodéfense immédiate,
ouais, pour moi c'est tu es tu es paumé
parce que c'est contre-productif ce que
tu fais et ça ne va pas servir le le la
cause que tu défends. Mais c'est juste
mon opinion. C'est-à-dire que à aucun
moment je dis que j'ai raison là. Et et
d'ailleurs depuis tout à l'heure, on est
d'accord que tout ce que je te raconte
c'est mon opinion.
Que tu nous racontes.
Oui. Tout ce que je te ce que je vous
raconte, tout ce que je te raconte euh
c'est de l'opinion. Donc paumé, c'est un
terme peut-être un peu dur, mais
combattre le désespoir,
construire
comment tu peux combattre le désespoir
quand tu as du chômage grandissant, une
concurrence mondiale, une guerre
économique,
des facteurs en désérance,
tu sais par exemple, alors je plante des
arbres au Sénégal, euh ça fait 9 ans que
je le fais, j'ai planté plus de 25000
moringas, on alphabétise des femmes
là-bas et on a on leur a appris à tirer
un revenu de ce moringa. ce moringa.
Ensuite, on le vend en Suisse pour
pouvoir faire un maximum de marge pour
le renvoyer au Sénégal. Et euh ça c'est
à mon échelle. J'ai commencé ça quand je
sortais de Normal Sup. Donc
c'était en 2009. Ouais. J'avais pris
l'argent que j'avais gagné avec ma
première prestation de conseil en
France.
C'est quoi Normal Suppelle-moi.
Alors j'ai fait biologie, je suis rentré
en biologie. Je vais être très honnête.
Normal Supesté pour moi. C'est un
mourroir intellectuel. C'est un Non non
mais je sais il faut se dire les choses
hein. C'est c'est pas compliqué. Si ça
marchait les gens l'auraient copié à
l'étranger. Tu sais quand personne ne
t'a copié, tu as deux solutions. Ou bien
tu te dis bon on on a chié dans la
voilà. Ou bien tu te dis euh on a
déconné ou bien tu te dis ah non c'est
l'exception culturelle française.
C'est pour ça qu'on m'aime ou qu'on me
déteste. Comme diraitant on dit de moi
ou trop de bien ou trop de mal jouis des
honneurs de l'exagération.
D'autres préconisations ?
Alors moi c'est surtout sur l'écologie
que j'interviens pour le le côté
optimisme. Tu sais je suis de la
génération, j'ai vu une vérité qui
dérange d'Algor. Euh j'ai trouvé que
c'était un film très intéressant. Il y a
quelques inexactitudes mais qui n'en
commet pas ? Et en fait ça c'est
l'écologie plutôt punitive, c'est-à-dire
vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous ne
savez pas pour les problèmes. Algor son
métier ça a été de faire ça.
Repars sur la contraradicalisation.
Ah pardon mais tu veux
Non mais on viendra sur l'écologie juste
après.
Alors
bah mes préconisations c'est de donner
beaucoup plus d'audience à l'islam
naturel. Euh tu
tu trouves qu'il y a de l'islamophobie
de l'islamophobie en France ? Alors,
islamophobie en France en général, oui,
il peut y en avoir. Il y en a qui se
sont réclamés islamophobes, donc oui, il
peut y en avoir. En tout cas, moi, j'en
ai vécu. Mais c'est un épouvantail de de
de voir ça, si tu veux se concentrer
là-dessus, c'est contre-productif parce
que ça crée un cycle de dette contre
dette. Genre, vous avez mal parlé de ma
religion, alors je vais vous engueuler.
Puis du coup, regardez, c'est tous des
[__] de fanatiques, ils nous
engueulent sur les réseaux, c'est ça
marche pas. Moi, je m'intéresse à ce qui
marche et simplement se contenter de
faire une spirale de on dénonce
l'islamophobie d'un côté puis avec
véhémance parce que on est énervé, je
comprends quand on attaque ta religion,
c'est forcément énervant. Donc bon, bah
du coup, tu tombes dans le travers de la
véhémance et la véhémance c'est
exactement ce qu'un islamophobe attend
de toi. Donc du coup, tu es à la place
où on t'attend et ça c'est
contre-productif.
Donc euh
il faut rappeler les faits historiques.
Les faits sont ttuus. Mais oui,
rappelons alors tu sais bon les faits
c'est pas tellement un mot que j'aime
parce que comme disait Nietzsche et puis
Richard Francis Burton, il y a surtout
des perspectives mais des choses de
base. Tu sais qu'on a retrouvé dans une
tombe viking une bague
avec marqué au nom de Dieu le clément le
miséricordieux parce que les Vikings
faisaient du commerce avec Bagdad au 9e
siècle et que il y a des vikings qui se
sont convertis à l'islam. Bon donc ce
choc des civilisations,
c'est juste faux. dire où qu'on regarde
dans l'histoire, on va me dire que les
Vikings étaient plus tolérants euh que
le français moyen ou que le Danois
d'aujourd'hui. C'est je ça j'y croirais
pas que le Viking est été plus tolérant
religieusement. Non. Que Charlemagne et
Haroun Al-Rashid ont eu des échanges
commerciaux et que Haroun Al Rashid a
offert un éléphant blanc à Charlemagne
qui s'appelait Abou Labas et qui est
encore aujourd'hui enterré à Ex la
Chapelle.
et que dit-on l'expression du travail
d'Arabes viendrait du fait positif donc
que Harun Al Rachid avait offert un
clpsre une horloge à eau à euh à
Charlemagne et que cette horloge s'étant
détraquée, personne à la cour, je sais
pas si on pouvait dire court à l'époque
ne pouvait la réparer et que Charlemagne
aurait dit l'essai c'est du travail
d'arabe parce que travail d'arabe à
l'époque signifiait hautement
mathématique puisque l'algèbre aljabar
c'est un mot arabe puisque
Les le X dans les équations, ça vient
des Arabes. Les Arabes utilisaient une
lettre qu'il prononçait re pour noter
l'inconnu dans une équation. Et cette
lettre qu'ils ont prononcé re, les
Espagnols l'ont latinisé avec un X
qu'ils prononçaient eux-mêmes reo en
Andalousie. Donc algorithme, c'est un
mot arabe. C'était la latinisation de du
mathématicien Alfarismi.
Donc pour moi,
c'est pas ce
les préconisations,
c'est pas ce combat de marionnette. Bah
tu vois la préconisation, elle est là
rappelé.
En fait, je peux pas faire mieux que
comment il s'appelait ? Martin Luther
King. Il a dit l'obscurité ne peut pas
chasser l'obscurité, il y a que la
lumière qui le peut.
Donc
est-ce que tu trouves que la communauté
musulmane, celle qui n'est pas de Tu
sais l'erreur de c'est de croire qu'il y
a une communauté musulmane en France si
tu veux, tu as des musulmans et
est-ce qu'il font est-ce qu'ils font de
la contreradicalisation ça ?
Ah bah à mon avis oui. À mon avis oui.
Oui. Dans mon expérience, oui. Le
problème c'est que comme disaient les
Indiens, un arbre qui tombe fait
beaucoup plus de bruit qu'une forêt qui
pousse. Et tu avais entendu parler des
scout musulmans de France toi ?
Oui.
Tu t'étais renseigné sur moi ou tu le
savais avant ? Je connais bien les
scout. Mais musulmans de France, tu
savais qu'ils avaient été présidents du
scouisme français ? De tout le scouisme
français.
Ça non.
Et pourtant, c'est avec des moyens
dérisoires. En face, tu avais euh tu
avais des moyens du golf.
C'est quoi c'est quoi le salut des scout
musulmans ? C'est
Oh, c'est c'est le standard. C'est euh
c'est le dire ça.
Tu peux le faire. Oui, c'est la lou la
louf qui protège, c'est loufto.
C'est le plus fort qui protège le plus
faible.
Exactement. Ouais. Donc bah d'une façon
générale, normalement c'est la louve qui
protège chez ses louf si tu le fais
comme ça avec deux doigts. Donc la louve
et c'est loufto. Mais effectivement
c'est le fort qui protège le faible.
C'est tout à fait correct. Ce qui est la
base du scooisme. Et le scootisme quand
tu regardes le symbole c'est un peu le
renouveau de la chevalerie. Tu sais les
chevaliers ils avaient le tortil.
C'était un un foulard qu'on enroulait
puis qu'on se mettait autour de la tête.
Bah les scout ils le mettent autour du
cou. Et c'est Baden Powell qui l'avait
fait parce que ça évoquait un peu la
chevalerie et les vertus chevaleresques.
Et le Scout, j'aime beaucoup la notion
de Scoot parce que Scout ça veut dire
qu'il éclaire.
L'éclaireur
pour moi c'est que c'est tu me demandais
les préconisations concrètes. Il faut
éclairer. Si on se remet dans un cycle
de haine de dette qui a payé quoi, qui
doit quoi, à qui, on ira nulle part.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'il faut arrêter
les politiques étrangères ? On s'amuse à
balancer des bombes sur tout le monde
pour moi. Alors non, moi je crois que
BHL, c'est un bon ministre de des
affaires étrangères.
BHL il est pas il a jamais été ministre
que je sache.
Non, c'est une boutade ironique.
Euh oui, Uzul en a Usul en a mieux parlé
que moi. Je suis pas d'accord avec tout
ce qu'il dit, mais c'est quelqu'un que
je respecte énormément et j'espère qu'il
sera ici un jour. D'ailleurs, je ça
m'empêche pas de respecter tout aussi
bien à ce lino, hein. J'ai été très ravi
que vous le interviewez ici, mais euh
papi triviale poursuite.
Ouais, mais non, mais j'ai vu les vôtres
hein. J'ai euh j'ai vu les vôtres et
j'ai trouvé que c'était bien foutu. Et
Schwir, vous l'avez interviewé, bravo.
C'est quelqu'un qui m'a que j'ai
découvert par UE justement et et pour
moi Et Schwir est un est un grand
monsieur. Donc bon, sur la partie BHL,
oui, avoir une politique étrangère
indépendante, ça serait mieux mais d'une
façon générale, c'est juste que ça
marche pas. Je veux dire, bombarder la
Libye, ça a pas marché. On peut tourner
ça dans tous les sens qu'on veut, ça n'a
pas marché. Euh aujourd'hui, la Libye
est une Somalie divisée en trois zones
avec un tribalisme, une destruction des
sites archéologiques, une catastrophe
totale.
Soit on tire les leçons de cette
catastrophe et comme dirait comme dirait
l'autre, on les coupables, soit oui, on
continue à déconner. Mais c'est clair
que ça ne sert pas les intérêts des
Français.
parce que tu te retrouves avec plus de
despelados quand tu fais ça.
Question d'internet. Alors, je la
découvre avec toi. Jacquali virgule, tu
étais souvent en accord avec ses propos
pour pas dire durant tout le débat.
N'as-tu pas décelé un double langage
d'inrogation ? L'as-tu senti sincère
dans ses propos ?
C'est une très bonne question.
Tu bosses en ce moment avec lui, je
crois.
Euh non, je alors j'ai bossé, j'ai fait
une confe avec lui une fois. J'ai
Tu es pas dans un groupe de travail avec
lui ?
Ah non,
d'accord.
Je Pourquoi tu as vu un truc comme ça ?
J'ai été j'avais donné des conseils sur
la méthode dit devenir soi mais fait
et en fait là le l'internaut donc il
faut préciser le contexte parle d'une
conf d'un d'une confe bien précise sur
Radio France si je me gours pas sur le
sucre on parlait pas géopolitique ça ça
donne déjà une réponse à notre ami
internaute. On parlait sucre on parlait
alimentation nutrition et là je n'ai pas
décelé à un moment un propos faux de
Jacques Atalli. Cela dit, euh moi c'est
quelqu'un qu'on m'avait vendu comme
étant un monstre he je veux dire du dans
la banlieue, on te le présente parfois
comme ça. Je te rappelle qu'il est
rentré dans l'art d'un certain polémiste
islamophobe très connu que je ne citerai
pas. Bah écoute, je ne le citerai pas.
Donc tu tu
Ça commence par un t.
Non non non, ça commence par un F. Et
euh et j'irai pas plus loin. Et je m'y
attendais pas.
Quelque chose que j'ai découvert
que je mets dans mon livre.
Il y a ce physicien Fritzwiki qui avait
une insulte préférée, c'était connard
sphérique.
Connard sphérique, ça veut dire sous
n'importe quel angle, tu es un connard.
S'il y a bien une chose que j'ai
apprise, c'est que ça ça n'existe pas.
Euh même le pire des connards, ce qui
n'est pas le cas, j'ai aucun problème à
le dire sur internet et que ça reste
gravé dans le marbre de Jacques Atali.
Mais même un gars odieux,
il existe un angle où tu pourrais parler
avec lui. Le problème c'est que dans les
on l'a pas encore trouvé hein.
Non mais ça parce qu'en fait dans les
médias tu présentes toujours le même
angle. Je te rappelle tu es un masque
personnel hein.
Ah non, j'ai trouvé des gens j'ai trouvé
des gens qui étaient qui étaient
particulièrement euh malhonnête ou
manquant de chevalerie avec qui j'ai pu
discuter parce que si tu veux tu as le
problème du fait qu'on on présente un
masque à notre puis dans la vie
professionnelle aussi. tu esi ton
métier. Quand tu demandes à quelqu'un,
quand tu lui demandes qu'est-ce que tu
fais dans la vie, tu prends quand même
la base que tu le définis par son
occupation,
ce qui est dangereux parce que ça réduit
l'homme. Un homme est bien plus que son
occupation. Et on le voit au 21e siècle
où les occupations changent, mais du
coup, tu présentes toujours le même
visage à quelqu'un. Et ça ça peut casser
le dialogue parce que tu vas rester du
coup dans des dans des sujets
euh bah où tu vas te friter avec lui
alors que tu aurais pu construire des
choses ensemble. Donc là, je suis
conscient du fait que je parle sur
internet, que je parle pas au point, que
je parle pas dans de la presse papier
classique et
j'ai pas peur de dire qu'al n'est pas du
tout celui qu'on croit vraiment.
La Libye, on va écluser. On va revenir
sur Jacques. Bah
la Libye,
la Syrie maintenant
si tu veux. Non mais attends, revenons
sur Jacques maintenant. Il y a un sujet
qu'il a toujours des peignoirs avec ses
initiales.
Ça je sa j'ai pas vécu chez lui, il ne
savait pas ce genre de truc. Non mais
sais que la dernière fois qu'on l'a
croisé, c'était mon mentor qui l'avait
fait venir au Fouets pour que je me
fasse les crous sur mec. Tuas pas honte
?
Non, j'ai pas honte.
C'est c'est leur problème
pour qu'on on puisse se faire les les
incisives sur son gras. Et il a il s'est
levé, il a dit "Je ne suis pas venu ici
pour me faire insulter en public." Et
mon mentor lui a dit "Mais tu peux
t'asseoir, tu te rascies." Il s'est
rassié. On discutait autour des
révolutions arabes, sa perspective au
niveau des réseaux sociaux.
Ça, je la connais pas celle-là, je
t'avoue c cette perspective là. Mèque
par exemple, on était pas d'accord sur
un truc, c'est que il avait dit, il est
issu de la tradition juive que la nature
est fondamentalement mauvaise. C'est le
mot qu'il avait utilisé et que c'est il
appartient à l'homme de la modifier. Je
crois qu'il avait utilisé un autre mot
que modifier, genre améliorer. Et ça,
bon, tu connais mes conférences, tu sais
que c'est l'opposé de ma vie. Tu sais
que c'est quand je parle de biométisme,
je dis la nature est plus maline que
nous, plus intelligente.
Mais ce qui est très intéressant, c'est
qu'il est d'accord avec ça aussi.
Moi, je viens d'une tradition où on
apprend par les paères d'opposé.
Et c'est ce qu'avait dit Roui. Je t'ai
je t'enseigne et là c'est Dieu qui
parle. Euh enfin, c'est le maître de
Roui qui qui rapporte qui interprète un
hadith qui dit "Je t'enseigne par les
opposés de sorte à ce que tu a deux
ailes pour voler."
Et bon, c'est le principe de la
dialectique en Occident.
Il est vrai que moi, je continue à
croire que la nature est plus brillante
que nous. Je pense que c'est objectif.
Tu veux parler du biomémitisme ?
Oui. Ou de la bioinspiration.
Je continue à croire mais objectivement.
C'est dire même sans invoquer les
mouvements actuel biomimétisme,
bioinspiration. Donc bioinspiration
c'est la science. Biomimétisme c'est le
mouvement global qui inclut
l'architecture, qui inclut les beauxarts
et cetera. Objectivement, on sait pas
refaire la nature. Donc oui, à partir de
là, elle est plus brillante que nous
parce qu'on sait pas la copier. Attends,
avant que tu passes sur le le
biomimétisme, je voudrais qu'on qu'on
ouvre une quand même on continue la
parenthèse géopolitique. La Syrie,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en Syrie ?
Bah là, il y a plus enfin là, si tu
veux, c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Qu'est-ce que tu entends par on ? Je te
par K d'orsais,
parce que d'oris est pas un peu
schizophré parce que moi je bosse pas au
qu d'orsais, donc je me sens pas dans le
euh que tu que tu es
français.
Oui, mais je malheureusement
malheureusement
on ne peut pas dire que le K d'Orscé
appartienne totalement au français.
Qu'est-ce que tu sous-entends avec ça ?
Bah je ne crois pas qu'il y ait, tu sais
que normalement quand une guerre est est
déclarée,
dans le temps, à une certaine époque que
les moins de 60 ans ne peuvent pas
connaître, on convoque le parlement et
on sollicite le peuple.
à ma connaissance, ça n'a pas été le cas
pour la Syrie
et je ne crois pas que si on faisait un
sondage,
voire même un vote, un référendum pour
savoir si la France doit s'impliquer
dans cette guerre de façon diplomatique
ou sur le terrain, je ne crois pas, je
n'ai pas souvenir que les Français se
soient prononcés.
Donc ce ne me concernait pas.
Maintenant en Syrie, euh il faut quand
même reconnaître que
que les partis basistes
qui sont tous prooviétiques
naturellement sont du coup des ennemis
désignés de notre politique étrangère.
Par conséquent, la même façon pour
Saddam Husen,
la guerre en Irak était une faramineuse
connerie.
Tu es bien conscient du fait que
j'utilise pas un langage diplomatique ?
Enfin conneries, j'aurais j'aurais
employé des mots un peu plus
quoi plus soft ou plus grave. Voilà.
Alors
non, si tu veux dire grave, tu aurais
dit crime.
Tu aurais dit il y a eu des innocents
qui ont été
tu dit génocide.
Génocide c'est quand tu cibles selon une
selon un groupe ethnique. Là en
l'occurrence on va pas faire de la
sémantique quand il y a eu plusieurs
millions de morts et de déplacer mais
en tout cas c'est un crime.
Qui a payé pour ce crime ? les Iraks.
Voilà. Mais ils ont ils l'ont pas
commis. Ils ont été les victimes.
Les commanditaires. Ont-ils payé ? Non.
Je pense que euh la Syrie a été un échec
diplomatique de grande ampleur, de très
grande ampleur
euh dont nous allons avoir, là je parle
en tant que français beaucoup de mal à
nous remettre
et qu'il est possible de nous en
remettre cela dit parce que il faut
qu'on tendre la main au russe.
Comment ? Parce que la question c'est
comment ? C'est
c'est simple de tendre la main en russe
? Non mais en Syrie enfit comment tu
sais c'est tu peux te friter avec un
pays en étant en lui tendant la main de
l'autre. Tu regardes les Russes avec la
Turquie, d'un côté les Turcs venait de
leur abattre un pilote et puis de
l'autre ils étaient en train d'essayer
de de concilier sur la mer noire. Donc
tu tu penserais à quoi ? Sur
que le coup d'état contre Erdogan ? Ça
les a vachement rapproché. Non. Bah
voilà, c'est tout à fait vrai. À se
demander même si euh bon, ils l'ont vu
venir en tout cas et je crois même
qu'ils l'ont informé si mes sources sont
sont exactes. Mais euh donc à quoi tu
pensais ? Parce que j'ai j'ai pas
tellement potassé le dossier syrien euh
mais qu'est-ce que tu aurais tu aurais
pensé à quoi pour la main tendue ?
Ici c'est moi qui pose des questions.
Non mais je sais bien mais ça m'empêche
pas de te considérer comme beaucoup plus
que un simple interrogateur et comme
quelqu'un qui a une position.
D'ailleurs, tu as pris position sur
Internet, sur le financement et sur les
les liens diplomatiques entre la France
et le Golf. Et cette position a été très
respectée sur le web ou très controversé
selon les sources. Mais respecté tout
court. Ben,
j'en suis persuadé. Mais donc tu as des
idées et quand tu pensais à m'aintendu,
je pense que tu y as réfléchi plus que
moi. Donc je serais je serais ravi.
Après tu décides si tu es euh si tu es
prêt à me donner ton opinion ou pas
parce que c'est vrai que toi aussi c'est
au débauté et je veux pas du tout te
c'est je suis pas là pour taculer à une
réponse. On
n pas là pour donner notre notre opinion
mais un jour un jour
mais si tu veux qu'on a un débat écoute
a on a un jour tu feras mon interview.
Ah j'en serai très honoré.
OK bon on passe à une autre question.
Les flux migratoires, qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait maintenant ?
Donc là, pareil, tu assumes en Europe,
en France et cetera.
Les flux migratoires, on va dire tout le
bordel qu'on a foutu. Déjà, les flux
migratoires économiques
et ensuite les flux migratoires de
guerre.
Tu vois, tu viens, tu voulais pas donner
ton opinion mais tu commences en disant
tout le bordel qu'on a foutu, tu vois.
Et donc là d'entrée de jeu, tu donnes
une opinion et tu sais bien que c'est
une opinion que je partage à dessin
hein. C'est fait à dessin. Bah tu sais
bien en plus là tu tu me primes quoi. Tu
vois c'est une opinion que je partage
euh comme disent les Américains, when
the shit h the fun quoi. Quand la merde
va toucher le ventilateur. Et là
aujourd'hui oui, on a un nombre de
déplacés très grand
et moi je t'avoue que je là je sais pas.
Il faudrait que j'ai le que j'ai un
dossier. J'ai travaillé dans les ce
qu'on appelle les PMA, les pays les
moins avancés et je sais qu'il n'y a pas
c'est ce même qui circule sur internet.
Comment voulez-vous régler le problème
migratoire ? Ne commencez pas une guerre
dans leur pays. Ne commencez pas une
guerre dans leur pays. Ne commencez pas
une guerre dans leur pays. Bon, il se
trouve que c'est ce qu'on a fait
aussi bien en Irak qu'en Libye et
ailleurs.
Une fois que c'est fait,
j'ai pas du tout le niveau de compétence
là tout de suite pour te dire ce que je
pense qu'il faudrait faire.
Je
Est-ce qu'on ouvre les frontières ?
Est-ce que Est-ce qu'on leur tend la
main vraiment ? Est-ce qu'on arrête de
les faire crever dans des camps de
réfugiés qui ne sont même pas aux normes
la plus grande descence ? Ce modèle là,
le camp de réfugié, la jungle comme on
dit, c'est
il y a rien de digne là-dedans.
Et là où il y a rien de digne, il peut
rien y avoir de bon.
Euh
donc ça déjà ça donne une décision si tu
veux.
Il y a quelqu'un que j'admire
que j'admire beaucoup. C'est le premier
grand président du club de Rome
et il a euh donc Bertrand Schneider
et Bertrand Schneeder
à mon avis saurait répondre à cette
question là parce qu'il a connu et il a
dû gérer l'époque où tu avais des
réfugiés allemands qui venaient en
France la preger
et qui venaient tu sais ils étaient à
une demi boîte de cornet de bef par
famille quoi et par jour.
Et euh
il a réglé résolu ce problème à
l'époque. Il était fait partie d'une
commission, je sais plus laquelle qui
s'occupait de ça.
Pour moi, la meilleure réponse devrait
être
obtenue de ce monsieur Bertrand, grand
monsieur Bertrand Schneeder. Euh parce
que bon, comme tu le sais, il faut
savoir déléguer, enfin déléguer, c'est
pas mon mon subalterne, mais il faut
savoir confier la réponse à un sujet que
tu maîtrises pas assez, à quelqu'un qui
le maîtrise mieux que toi. Et là, en
l'occurrence, je pense que tu vois, mais
je te donne quand même une opinion
puisque je te je te flèche. Non, mais je
te flèche vers quelqu'un.
Euh je te flèche vers quelqu'un.
Tu nous flèches.
Oui, je vous flèche. Pardon ? Ouais.
Bon euh, on aura pas assez de temps pour
faire la géopolitique. On va passer à un
autre sujet.
On a fait pas mal là déjà.
Ouais, on a fait 5 % de ce qu'on voulait
faire.
Alors
mais je te rappelle que c'est 1h15 ton
format ou
Ouais non des fois on peut faire 3h mais
le problème c'est que on a des rappeurs
qui viennent après
et ouais il y a des rappeurs que j'ai un
que je vous ai un petit peu enfoncé
comme ça làouais t'inquiète on leur a
fait un peu peur hein tu sais qu'ils ont
failli pas venir he
Ah au départ tu sais que j'aurais adoré
qu'on le fasse ensemble hein que
tu étais pas content de ça mais j'ai vu
que vous aviez fait
vous aviez fait des interviews multipl
il y avait plusieurs canapés ça je
savais pas que Serview faisait ça
si si des fois on fait 4 5 qu bon on
passe à un autre sujet
ouais
première Première question d'Internet,
comment mettre en place concrètement sa
fameuse économie de la connaissance ?
La bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'il y a pas
besoin de la mettre en place, elle est
déjà là. L'économie de la connaissance,
beaucoup de gens pensent que tu sais
une, comment dire, c'est une mode. C'est
genre c'est une préconisation. En fait,
c'est pas une préconisation, c'est une
observation. C'est-à-dire que l'économie
de la connaissance, c'est déjà la plus
ancienne. L'être humain échangeait des
savoirs bien avant d'échanger des
matières premières, bien avant les
enfort d'huile d'olive, bien avant les
sacs de blé, bien avant l'apparition des
écritures et même avant l'apparition
d'homos sapiens sapience. Bien l'être
humain, pas l'être humain du coup, mais
les hommes inidés, ils échangeaient les
savoirs. Un site de pêche, un territoire
de chasse, quels champignons sont
comestibles ? Quels buissons peuvent te
fournir des becs que tu peux manger et
macérer ? Comment tailler un silex ?
Comment fabriquer un arc ? Tout ça c'est
de la connaissance. L'être humain
échange de la connaissance depuis bien
plus longtemps que ce qu'on appelle le
commerce actuel. Simplement, la plupart
des humains ont un on a tous les humains
ont un cerveau de primat. Et un cerveau
de primat, qu'est-ce que ça voit en
premier ? Ça voit le côté tangible, la
matière, tout ce qui est concret. Notre
cerveau n'a aucun problème avec le
concret. Tout ce qui est tangible et
bien il peut l'appréhender.
La méthode de Singapour.
Alors, méthode de Singapour, c'est ça.
Ouais. [__] tu es tu es au taquet.
Moi j'aime bien voir les gens qui font
leur taf comme ça. Pas de taf.
Bah en tout oui, c'est mieux. Alors
c'est qu'en plus tu fais ça par plaisir.
Exactement.
[__] si j'étais pas si loin, je te
checkerai mec. Mais
prenez ces empreintes digitales là tout
de suite. Ça y est, je l'ai eu. Euh en
fait d'ailleurs, tu sais qu'il faut
faire gaffe. Il paraît qu'il faut même
plus faire le signe
V, tu sais, devant une caméra.
Ouais. Non, mais ça c'est c'est rien. On
discutera parlera après. Mais euh Oui,
méthode de Singapour consiste à rendre
les maths plus concrets pour que le
cerveau les appréhende plus facilement.
Et c'est vrai que l'économie de la
connaissance, elle a l'air bah elle est
abstraite parce que la connaissance
c'est abstrait et en général ce qui est
abstrait, on y pense pas. Mais la
connaissance elle est partout. Et
aujourd'hui quand tu regardes bon les
points de la sacro sein de croissance,
d'ailleurs je vais revenir sur la notion
de croissance euh et bien mais c'est de
l'immatériel qui aujourd'hui là il
n'existe pas de transaction économique
sans qu'il y ait quelque part de
l'immatériel qui soit impliqué. Ça
n'existe pas. Tu ne peux pas vendre
quelque chose et c'est connu en
économie. C'est un principe que
normalement en économie, l'acheteur doit
mieux connaître son produit que le
vendeur, sinon il se fait baiser. Et si
tu veux gagner une transaction, un
acheteur prospère doit toujours mieux
connaître son produit que son vendeur.
Donc déjà de base, pardon, un vendeur
prospère doit toujours mieux connaître
le produit que l'acheteur.
Pardonnez-moi.
Quand tu dis économie de la
connaissance, tu as pas un problème de
vocabulaire ?
Alors pourquoi tu tu verrais ça comme un
problème de vocabulaire ?
Économie. Économie, marché.
Non, économie, tu sais d'où ça vient.
Je t'écoute.
Ça y est. Et puis le moment où j'en
profite pour me rafraîchir. Alors
estime-toi heureux, tu as de l'eau.
Et oui, ça aurait pu être pire. Alors en
fait le mot économie vient des
physiates, donc des penseurs français
qui s'intéressaient, tu sais, bassement
à la façon dont les quasiment les abli
génère du cash. Tu sais, les abayes dans
l'ancien régime, c'était des machines à
cash. Et d'ailleurs, Guillaume le
conquérant, il a assis son autorité
économique sur les abeilles et la
première chose qu'il a faite quand il
est allé en Angleterre, c'est de faire
le recensement de tous les biens de type
Abacio et parabio avec le Doms Day Book.
Bon et à l'époque donc tu as des
philosophes en France au 18e siècle
notamment Kenet qui veulent faire un
échonom.
Donc on mesure ce qui vient de la terre
et ce qui crée du pognon. Je te parle de
choses transformées hein. La chartreuse
la bière d'abaye, le papier
la calorie.
Oui. De la calorie ou pas ? Parce que ça
peut être du papier.
La vraie question La vraie question
c'est tu tu préconises euh la
transmission des savoirs parce que ça
multiplie en fait ton patrimoine si j'ai
bien résumé.
Oui tout à fait.
Ton patrimoine, tu l'as bien fait à
partir de calories que tu as consommé.
Alors non, là tu vois la dimension
matérielle du truc. Bah et si moi je lis
un livre que je je suis obligé de manger
par exemple le petit gâteau ou des
choses comme ça pour pouvoir donner à
manger on Mais attends parlant justement
de ce sujet fascinant qui est économie
matérielle économie immatérielle il faut
pas opposer les deux simplement
l'économie matérielle est dans une
impasse aujourd'hui parce qu'elle est
idiote. Elle est idiote. Que le mar de
café qu'on utilise que 1 % de la
biomasse quand on se fait un café c'est
idiot. Quelle est la définition de
l'idiotsie ? Un manque de connaissance.
Moi, tu sais, j'aime beaucoup Pierre
Rabi. J'espère que tu l'auras ici
d'ailleurs un jour. Et euh tu sais, rien
n'est parfait chez aucun dépenseur. Je
veux dire, petite parenthèse importante,
tu peux détecter quelqu'un qui n'est pas
mur intellectuellement à ce qui te dira
"Ne mangez pas de cette pomme, j'ai
entendu dire qu'il y avait des pépins
dedans." Donc arrêtez de faire des
tartes tatin, il y a des pépins dans les
pommes. Dans le débat intellectuel,
c'est souvent ça. Oh, tu sais mais
machin, il a dit des trucs, "Prends ce
qu'il y a à manger dedans, c'est pas la
même chose pour tout le monde.
Cuisine-le bien, raffine-le. Si on
s'était arrêté au goût naturel des fes
de cacao, on aurait jamais eu le
chocolat. parle de là. Non
non, je parle de n'importe qui en fait.
Je peux te parler de Laurent Alexandre,
je peux te parler de Cédric Vilani, je
peux te parler de n'importe quel penseur
bien sûr. Et euh je peux te parler de
n'importe quel penseur. Dans n'importe
quel penseur, tu as des choses à tu as
de la peau à enlever, tu as des des
pépins à enlever et puis tu as de la
chair que tu peux manger ou cru ou
cuisiner. Et donc c'est pareil pour
Gunter Poly, c'est pareil pour tous les
grands penseurs de notre époque. Et donc
si tu veux dans l'économie de la
connaissance, c'est pareil. Dans Pierre
Rabi, pour en revenir à ça, il parle de
décroissance, il parle de sobriété
heureuse, il parle de décroissance. Bah
là automatiquement tu vas te dire
"Attends euh c'est pas possible Idris il
est en contradiction avec ça parce que
c'est il te parle il dit "Attends,
pourrait-on avoir une croissance infinie
?" La connaissance est infinie. Comment
démontre-t-on que la connaissance est
infinie ? C'est très simple. Toute
démonstration constitue une
connaissance. Or, on sait depuis les
années 20 que la collection des
démonstrations mathématiques est
infinie. On sait depuis Brouwer et et
Guddle qu'il existe un nombre, une
diversité infinie, c'est une collection.
On parle pas d'ensemble, c'est beaucoup
trop grand pour être un ensemble. Qu'il
existe une collection infinie. de
démonstrations, de propositions qui sont
vraies et démontrables et ça ça démontre
que la connaissance est infinie. J'ai vu
qu'un mathématicien amateur avait dit
que la connaissance pouvait pas être
infini. Bon, malheureusement cet
argument n'est pas valable. La
connaissance est bien entendue infinie.
Et bien je dis pourrait-on avoir une
croissance infinie si elle était basée
sur la connaissance ? On sait que la
croissance infinie c'est pas possible
matériellement. Je sais plus qui c'est
qui a dit euh
quelques économistes.
Voilà, il y a que Non, c'est Oui, mais
qui c'est qui a dit ça ?
euh celui qui pense que la croissance
infinie est possible et soit fou, soit
un économiste. Mais là, on parle de
croissance matérielle. Il est véritable,
il est authentique qu'on peut pas avoir
une croissance infinie. D'abord, alors
si on veut être totalement rigoureux
scientifiquement, on va dire "Bon,
première loi de la thermodynamique, la
quantité d'énergie dans l'univers est
fixe et la masse représente de
l'énergie. Donc la quantité de masse
dans l'univers est fixe, donc tout ce
qui est massif est fini. Et donc, il ne
peut pas y avoir de choses matérielles,
tangibles, massive et infinies. Donc il
ne peut pas y avoir de croissance
matérielle infinie. C'est vrai. Bon, on
a même pas besoin d'invoquer l'univers.
On peut parler de la planète Terre, elle
est finie. Mais aujourd'hui, le ratio
connaissance matière, il est très
mauvais. Regarde la façon dont on gère
nos déchets. Regarde la façon dont on
gère nos stocks de pêche. On est encore
chasseur cuueilleur dans les océans. On
est en 2018 et on pêche du poisson
sauvage majoritairement. C'est débile.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que nous
devons faire. Je pense sincèrement que
l'être humain a un désir intrinsèque
d'infini. Je pense que l'être humain, tu
ne peux pas lui enlever une sorte de
désir, bon qui pour moi est d'origine,
tu pourrais dire spirituelle, mais un
pour Platon, ce serait de l'ego. Tu
sais, Gandy avait dit, il y a
suffisamment de ressources sur terre
pour nourrir tout le monde, mais pas
l'ego de tout le monde. L'ego aspire à
l'infini, mais s'il essaie de rassasier
son désir d'infini par le monde
matériel, il est mort et le monde
matériel va mourir avec lui. Le seul
monde qui peut rassier le désir d'infini
de l'humain, c'est le monde immatériel.
La connaissance et au-dessus la sagesse
qui est plus puissante que la
connaissance. La sagesse est supérieure
à la connaissance. Mais
c'est quoi la sagesse ?
La connaissance de soi. Tous les grands
sages à travers toutes les époques ont
systématiquement ramené cette réalité
qui est que la sagesse, c'est la
connaissance de soi.
Et là, tu vas me parler de Marc Orel
avant. Non, non, je vais te parler de de
Chilon 2, la CDM. Je vais te parler de
Zoroastre, je vais te parler de
Confucius, de Lautse et bien entendu de
Marc Orel. Mais Marc Orel, c'est plus en
géopolitique que j'aime le citer parce
que pour moi son stoïisme s'applique aux
États. Quand Marc Orel te dit que les
gens ne désirent pas ce qui est bon pour
eux, ça marche avec les États aussi. Les
États ne désirent pas ce qui est bon
pour eux. Et la notion d'intérêt
national, elle est très dangereuse parce
qu'elle présuppose que l'on sait ce qui
est bon pour l'État. Et quand tu
regardes l'histoire en particulier de
France, quand tu penses tu as Clémanceau
Clémanceau quelqu'un qui est très
intéressant, c'est quand même à lui
qu'on doit la seconde guerre mondial.
S'il avait pas imposé le dictate de
Versailles, s'il avait pas été aussi
hardcore
avec les Allemands,
avec les Allemands, on aurait pas eu la
Seconde Guerre mondiale. Donc les États
ne savent pas ce qui est bon pour eux.
C'est plutôt pour ça que je cite Marc
Orel. Et pour envenir à cette opposition
entre croissance matérielle et
croissance immatérielle, quand par
exemple Pierre Rabi parle de sobriété
heureuse, et bien pour moi qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ? ce qui nous propose en fait
une croissance bien meilleure qui est la
croissance immatérielle. L'humain ne
peut pas croître matériellement,
indéfiniment, on le sait. Bon, ça tombe
bien démographiquement. Toutes les
analyses confirment que l'Afrique est
entrée en transition démographique et
que c'est le dernier continent et qui
n'y était pas rentré. Quand tu regardes
maintenant les chiffres, que tu essaies
d'être bien objectif et pas alarmiste,
tu vois que la Chine est en récession
démographique, tu vois que le Japon, la
Corée sont en récession démographique
grave même.
Ils sont à 1.1 enfant par femme, c'est
catastrophique. Pour ça continue, il
nous reste pas beaucoup de temps. Donc
le Non, c'est c'est Et donc ce que je
voulais dire sur cette notion de
croissance matérielle, croissance
immatérielle, c'est que l'être humain a
un désir intrinsèque d'infinité. Ce
désir d'infinité est pathologique s'il
essaie d'être assouvi par le monde
tangible, par le monde matériel. Le seul
monde qui est à même et qui est destiné,
si tu le veux, à assouvir notre désir
d'infinité, c'est le monde immatériel.
Et ça c'est la connaissance et la
sagesse. Et donc quand Pierre Rabi parle
de décroissance et de sobriété heureuse,
on oublie de mentionner avec une analyse
un peu plus profonde de son discours
qu'en fait ça nous propose également une
croissance qui est celle de l'âme si tu
veux, de l'âme au sens de Platon,
c'est-à-dire de la connaissance et de la
sagesse.
Où est-ce que tu places l'intelligence
artificielle dans tout ça ? Alors Lia,
c'est très intéressant euh parce que
effectivement il y a le sujet du revenu
universel que je défends que je ne
défendrai jamais aussi bien que Gaspar
Kenig qui pour moi a été le
j'espère qu'il sera là aussi d'ailleurs
tiens je fais un peu de pub parce que
Gaspar il est vraiment très très bon et
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu penses comme
Laurent Alexandre que le le revenu
universel c'est une idée d'extrême
droite
il Alors le revenu universel tu sais
qu'effectivement tu peux l'interpréter
comme de droite ou de gauche euh
l'intelligence artificielle
il y a de alors il y a deux écoles sur
le Ah oui pardon tu veux qu'on parle de
l'IA ou du revenu.
Allez, vas-y, go.
Sur le revenu universel, il y a deux
écoles. Il y a euh l'école de ce
blogueur assez brillant et assez
tranchant qui vous soutient d'ailleurs,
c'est Hable H16
et euh qui dit et qui a raison, un un
gouvernement qui peut tout donner, il
peut aussi tout te prendre.
Et donc, à partir du moment où c'est
l'État qui te donne un revenu universel,
tu deviens l'obligé de l'État alors que
c'est censé être le contraire en
démocratie. Donc pour moi, il a raison
de ce point de vue-là. Euh ma vision du
revenu universel,
ça serait de dire ma vision idéale, mais
c'est là aussi qu'on s'entendrait pas
par exemple avec Jackali, mais malgré le
respect que je peux avoir sur d'autres
opinions, mais pour lui l'inflation
c'est un impôt sur les pauvres et je
pense que le revenu universel devrait
être la création monétaire qui part du
peuple. C'est-à-dire que pour moi en
fait le meilleur impôt c'est la planche
habillée. C'està dire tu prélèves plus
rien. Tu dis mon gouvernement, mes
services publics, je les finance avec ma
monnaie.
Donc avec de l'inflation.
Oui mais de toute façon de l'inflation
tu en as toujours. Je te rappelle que
l'inflation est bien moins pire que la
déflation.
Ah bah en général
tu sais comment tu sais commence
l'inflation, tu sais pas quandion. OK.
Et la stack flation
ex la stack flation c'est le pire. Bah
c'est le Japon quoi. Donc la enfin la
déflation le Japon c'est de la
déflation. La stacflation c'est les
États-Unis dans les années 70 ou je sais
plus quand. Mais pour moi donc le revenu
universel idéal ça sera ça. Ça serait de
dire qu'en fait la création monétaire
part du peuple. Tu imagines un monde où
en fait ton salaire vient du fait que
c'est toi qui représente la création
monétaire et donc la création monétaire
part de l'humain. Bon c'est complètement
utopique ce que je raconte he mais
c'est utopique parce que toutes les
banques centrales sont privées madame
bon voilà c'est pour ça que c'est
utopique mais ridicule dangereux
évident. Pour en revenir à Lia, euh il y
a un scénariste hollywoodien que j'ai
cité dans une tribune que j'ai faite
dans le point euh qui qui est consultant
pour James Cameron, tu sais, pour la la
franchise Terminator. Il a été il m'a
donné la plus belle métaphore que j'ai
eu sur Lia, il m'a dit "Lia, c'est comme
l'eau. Euh l'eau c'est fait pour avoir
des comportements émergents. Ça a des
comportements émergents. C'est pour ça
que l'eau est le fluide du vivant connu
parce que elle a des comportements
émergents. Alors dans le vivant, non
mais tu as la neige, tu as les tsunami.
Et les comportements émergents de l'eau,
ça inclut des des catastrophes. La vraie
il a effectivement les algorithmes
évolutionnaires,
la singularité.
Bah alors la singularité c'est si elle
devient plus intelligente que nous, ce
qui est loin d'être le cas. Euh
aujourd'hui, les androrithmes sont plus
puissants que les algorithmes. Sinon Waz
ne se serait pas vendu 976 millions à
Google. Waz prédit la circulation en
utilisant l'intelligence humaine
collective et en se faisant, ils sont
meilleurs que Google Maps. Or, Google
est une entreprise DIIA. C'est ce qu'il
déclare en tout cas. Donc il ne faut pas
oublier que les entrorythmes sont plus
puissants que les algorithmes depuis
l'aube des temps, avant même que les
algorithmes n'existent. On est très
impressionné par le fait qu'un robot de
Boston Dynamics peut faire un salto. On
est très impressionné par le fait que
Léol a été battu par Alpha Go. Mais le
jeu de go n'est absolument pas l'appex
de l'intelligence humaine. Lia
aujourd'hui
c'est Starcraft 2 précisément. Starcraft
2.
C'est quoi ton pseudo dessus ?
Non mais non après tuas des mecs qui
vont venir me challenger et tout. Je
rentrerai pas dans ce dans ce jeu-là.
Euh en plus je dose de moins en moins.
J'ai regardé mon level là. Je suis un
peu je suis vraiment devenu mauvaise.
Pas bonjour ào.
Ah bah on n pas du tout de la même
branche les garçons là. Mais euh ah oui,
sur l'IA, elle nous interroge sur notre
propre intelligence et elle nous ramène
à notre propre intelligence parce que
quand l'IA peut nous prendre un métier,
c'est souvent que c'était un métier du
type les temps modernes de Charlie
Chaplin avec euh les euh les les les euh
les clés de 12 et tu es en train de
visser des boulons toute la journée.
Donc il est assez essentiel de de
s'interroger sur l'intelligence humaine,
sur ce qu'elle est vraiment et sur où
est l'avantage compétitif de l'humain.
Il ne faut pas oublier que l'IA ne sait
pas survivre dans la nature. Le test
d'intelligence le plus fondamental, le
plus non négociable si tu veux, c'est la
survie. C'est aussi simple que ça. En
biologie, le vrai test d'intelligence,
c'est la capacité à résister à
l'éradication.
LIA ne passe absolument pas ce test. Et
donc penser une seule seconde que
l'intelligence humaine se mesure au jeu
de go, c'est se fourvoyer complètement
et nous ramène à cette réalité. Ça ne
signifie pas qu'elle ne pose pas plein
de danger. Je te rappelle que Poutine a
dit celui qui dominera l'IA dominera le
monde. Il a dit ça. Il a tout à fait
raison malgré le fait qu'il ne soit pas
spécialiste de l'IA parce que il sait
que Napoléon avait dit la puissance
d'une armée, c'est sa masse multipliée
par sa vitesse. Enfin la quantité de
mouvement pour être précis en physique.
Et donc une intelligence artificielle
c'est la nouvelle arme automatique de
demain. Tu vois un fusil, il est évident
qu'un fusil qui se recharge à la bouche
fait moins de dégâts qu'un fusil
automatique qui te dégaîne 900 coups par
minute. Euh il en va de même pour Lia.
Elle peut faire beaucoup plus qu'un
coup, elle peut faire une décision et
sur un champ de bataille, une décision
c'est beaucoup plus dangereux qu'un coup
de feu. Elia peut prendre un milliard de
décisions par seconde et là se trouve le
danger. Donc par exemple, je cautionne
Elon Musk quand il dit il faut une
convention de Genève des armes
autonomes. Ça, j'en suis je suis tout à
fait d'accord et je pense qu'il faut
éveiller les internautes à ce sujet
ayant une convention de Genève des armes
des armes autonomes et surtout des
moratoires sur la présence d'armes
autonomes dans la sphère civile.
Tu as pas l'impression qu'il y a des
mégalomanes aux manettes de temps en
temps ?
Si. Ah mais il y en a toujours aux
manettes. Des mégaloman si tu veux le
l'ego humain est un peu ce qui fait
tourner le monde. Et euh c'est
d'ailleurs c'est les limites. Euh
est-ce que tu as pas l'impression que
ceux qui entraînent les intelligences
artificielles sont un peu mégal ? un peu
non beaucoup.
Euh il existe dans le transhumanisme
une
une résurgence pleine et entière de
l'ogénisme. C'est un fait. Il existe le
transhumanisme est une corde avec
plusieurs faisceaux. Donc on peut pas
parler d'un transhumanisme mais il
existe parmi dans cette corde un fil de
couleur eugénique avec des gens qui
disent il va falloir stériliser les gens
qui ont pas un QI de temps. Il va
falloir et euh ça bien sûr c'est
dangereux
mais j'oublie pas non plus
et là c'est quelqu'un c'est un derich
qui te parle que très souvent
tu tournes.
Tous les deriches sont pas tourneurs.
Euh mais euh que très souvent quelque
chose de négatif peut engendrer un bien.
Quelque chose. Tu sais, il faut pas
oublier que les Russes avaient parlé du
lisencoïme parce que pour les
soviétiques, la génétique était une
science bourgeoise. Mais tu sais
pourquoi ? C'est parce qu'à l'époque la
totalité des financements qui allaient à
la génétique venait de société de
génique et que la fondation Rockfeller
entre autres mais d'autres Henry Ford
avait financé des recherches en
génétique et c'était mal mais ça a donné
un grand bien.
Qui a donné un grand mal par la suite ?
Oui.
Qui peut redonner un grand bien demain ?
C'est ce que disait un maître
bouddhiste, je sais plus lequel. les
fleurs à pistil noir ont des pétales
blancs et les fleurs à à pistil blanc on
ont des pétales noirs. Et c'est assez
vrai, c'est-à-dire que tu peux avoir des
choses qui sont qui ont les ratrocements
négatifs là tout de suite et qui peuvent
enfanter des choses positives.
Alors, il va falloir qu'on qu'on te pose
la dernière question qui est laissée un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Mais avant ça, je vais te lire les trois
quatre questions que qui s'affichent sur
l'écran
parce qu'il faut que je respecte, il
faut qu'on respecte notre parole. On a
le
on voit les logos là, je suis désolé,
on s'en fout.
Donc première question, la cryptoonnaie
d'uniteur, la G1 dit June.
Attends, redis-moi ça lentement.
Les cryptomonnaies, qu'est-ce que tu en
penses ? OK.
Alors, ce plan technologique par faut
faire tout à la fois.
Non non, tu choisis celle que tu veux
parce qu'on va plus avoir le temps.
OK.
Comment la technologie peut résoudre les
problèmes énergétiques alors que cette
dernière fait partie du problème lotecch
point interrogation.
Comment désutraliser la le transfert de
connaissance ? Que pensent-il de la
baisse du cuit des Français ? Alors, la
baisse du QD français, c'est une
légende, hein. C'est euh statistiquement
parlant, c'est pas du tout rigoureux les
statistiques qui ont qui ont décrété ça.
Et dans mon bouquin, j'en parle, euh il
y a notamment le test qui avait été
utilisé, c'était un temps de réaction,
tu sais. Et parce que pour avoir des
statistiques sur la baisse des QI, il
faut avoir 100 ans de stade, 150 ans de
stad. Donc, tu es obligé d'utiliser un
test qui date d'il y a 150 ans et qui a
un temps de réaction. Et ce test pour
l'avoir pratiqué moi-même quand j'étais
à Cambridge et quand j'étais assistant
dans dans le dans le ce laboratoire de
psychoacoustique à Cambridge, je l'ai
pratiqué, j'ai vu qu'en fait ce test, tu
es moins bon quand tu te poses des
questions, c'estàdire quand tu penses à
autre chose. Et penser à autre chose, ça
veut pas dire avoir un mauvais QI. Donc
ça c'est pour répondre à cette question
là. Sur sur les cryptos
euh elles sont une bouffée d'oxygène sur
le plan technologique actuel. Euh, elles
font se poser plein de questions sur le
qu'est-ce qu'une monnaie ? Bon, je
rappelle pour nos nos internautes que un
Bitcoin ou une crypto, c'est uniquement
un billet de banque dont on a gardé que
le numéro de série pour simplifier et
c'est même pas une simplification, euh
comment dire euh qui triche, quoi. Euh,
une crypto, c'est un billet de banque
dont on a gardé que le numéro de série
et dont on a un algorithme qui permet de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse pas le
dépenser deux fois. C'est juste ça une
cryptomonnaie. Et ça c'est génial en soi
d'avoir une de réduire le billet de
banque à son numéro de série et de faire
en sorte qu'on ait un algo qui
garantisse qui ne puisse pas être
falsifié.
Et ça nous amène plein de choses. Tu
regardes les travaux de Bernard Liot
dont j'espère aussi qu'il sera à ma
place très bientôt. Bernard Liuter que
tu trouves dans le documentaire demain,
il te parle des écosystèmes monétaires
et les cryptos peuvent amener ça. Comme
d'habitude, on voit que le côté négatif
sur les cryptos aujourd'hui. On voit les
arnaques de certaines ICO, on voit les
le blanchiment d'argent avec Bitcoin.
Mais moi justement et c'est là que tu
vois le yinel yang les fleurs au pistil
noir ou les fleurs au pistil blanc,
derrière la controverse des cryptos, il
y a une libération économique majeure
dont les acteurs économiques n'ont pas
encore pris conscience. Et tu le vois
avec bon le l'inénarable
commissionnement d'un d'un gars de la
Banque de France pour parler des cryptos
en France, Gaspar Kenig en a mieux parlé
que moi pour dire que c'était aussi
ridicule que d'avoir un ancien du
Minitel pour parler d'Internet. Note que
ça a été fait en 95. Et bien euh cette
les cryptos pour moi sont davantage une
libération
mais elle ne nous dispense pas d'esprit
critique. Euh et donc en terme
d'investissement, faut faire très
attention. Bah je vous renvoie au fait
que à partir du moment où Nabila s'est
mis à vendre du Bitcoin, il fallait
surtout pas en acheter.
Euh la G1, la June, tu connais, ça te
parle ? Cette monnaie qui inclut le
revenu universel. Ah oui, c'est ça.
C'est une nouvelle crypto. Je l'ai pas
suivie celle-là donc je vais pas pouvoir
en parler des masses. Mais il y avait
une autre question sur l'énergie. Je
crois bien. Il faut quand même pas
oublier que le problème alors si on se
place du point de vue de Tesla, pas de
l'entreprise de l'homme, le problème
énergétique n'est qu'un problème de
connaissance.
Pour Nicolas Tesla, c'était ça. Nicolas
Tesla, il a été très clair là-dessus.
Bon après, qu'on soit d'accord avec lui
ou pas, c'est un autre sujet. Mais pour
Nicolas Tesla, le problème énergétique
était un problème de connaissance. D'un
point de vue aujourd'hui le problème du
gaspillage énergétique aussi bien du
solaire que de l'hydrolien que du que
des éclairs. Mec, si on avait des
comment on appelle ça ? Des gigas
condensateurs, je sais plus gig il en
parle Musk tu as tu peux avoir un demi
gigw qui tombe sur certains éclairs en
un coup on les garde pas. Il y a plein
de sources énergétiques que nous
n'exploitons pas et si nous ne les
exploitons pas c'est parce que nous
manquons de connaissance
ou doit y en avoir plein encore dans les
coffres. Il y a ça aussi effectivement
qui est une possibilité sur laquelle
comme tu le sais je me garderai bien de
me prononcer.
Dernière question d'internet. Comment la
technologie peut résoudre le problème
énergétique ? Celle-là on l'a déjà posé
alors que cette dernière fait partie du
problème tech. OK.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations
d'impérissable. Une bouteille à la mer.
Richard Francis Burton. N'attendez
d'applaudissement que de vous-même.
Vous n'êtes libre que d'ailleurs. C'est
ce que dit Burton précisément. Il vit le
plus noble et il meurt le plus noble,
celui qui fait et qui suit ses propres
lois. Et cette capacité à avoir son
législateur intérieur
et à s'y suivre, à s'y fixer,
à ne pas vivre dans les idées des
autres. Ce qu'avait dit Steve Jobs à ce
fameux discours de Stanford. Ce qui est
vrai, c'est-à-dire que quand vous vivez
dans les dogmes de quand vous vivez dans
un dogme, vous vivez dans la pensée de
quelqu'un d'autre.
Nous sommes à une époque où nous avons
la plus pour la plupart dans dans le
monde le monde riche un toit mais nous
n'avons pas encore un toit intellectuel.
La capacité à construire sa propre
maison est un moyen d'émancipation
mais la capacité à construire sa propre
maison intellectuelle l' encore plus.
Donc ne vous laissez absolument pas
dominer par des modes de pensée ou par
des conditionnements.
C'est tous les travaux d'Idricha. que
j'encourage vivement les internautes à à
lire.
Ne vous laissez pas piloter
par le conditionnement. Moi, c'est la
première chose que j'ai faite et c'est
pour ça aujourd'hui que je suis un homme
libre.
Un livre à conseiller. Qu'est-ce que tu
lis en ce moment ?
Euh bah en ce moment, tu sais, je suis
en comment dire en repas complet. Là, je
lis des je lis des méos et des je lis
pas de de gros bouquins en ce moment.
Moi, le livre que je conseille, c'est la
Cassida de Richard Francis Burton, mais
elle a pas été traduite en français.
Euh donc pour les anglophones qui nous
qui nous qui nous écoutent, lisez la
cassida de Richard Francis Burton.
C'était un un type remarquable qui
parlait 29 langues couramment et qui
était extraordinairement controversé de
son vivant comme de sa mort et qui est
selon moi un des plus grands hommes de
son temps. Sinon bien sûr, j'encourage
de lire les travaux de Gunter Poly. Pour
moi, c'est un des penseurs majeurs de
notre époque.
Idrissam. Merci.
Merci à vous.
Couper.
[Musique]